you should have stayed home
don't feel bad it was never going to work
you depend on others for your strength
I depend on no one you should have stayed away now you're going to die with your
friends
I see you changed your mind Titans are my family is the Titans
don't make me kill you
what's next for us
I don't know
it's the million dollar question
seat belts
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my Titans finale video we
finally have a version of Nightwing on
the show they had their big faceoff with
Deathstroke there was a big post-credit
scene teasing what's happening in season
3 we get a whole bunch of Batman so I'll
break everything down if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the easter-egg videos there's a
bunch of DC trailers coming next week
too that I'll explain at the end of the
video most of you probably saw the
post-credits scene title and knew that
there would be spoilers in this video
but I'll say it one more time
careful for spoilers for the end of
Titan season 2 but quick catch up to
where we got to this point
Nightwing gets his brand new Nightwing
costume from the same people that make
all of Batman's suits and the other
Robin costumes they made the last
version of the Robin costume that he
wore a long time ago that they burned in
season 1 they spent all of the last
episode explaining how it's supposed to
be more agile make it easier for him to
dodge attacks which you see him do
during this fight with Deathstroke
incorporate more of his acrobatic circus
training into his fighting style move in
fight more like comic book Nightwing
does which he does during this fight
Ravager is also wearing her comic book
Ravager suit she hasn't worn it in the
present until now but we've seen her
wear it in flashbacks before as we all
expected they were doing a version of
Judas contract with Ravager instead of
Tara so they changed her backstory a
little bit this version of the character
is the illegitimate daughter of
Deathstroke she goes to train with him
and learns that because he was modified
genetically by hive to give him his
special regeneration powers he passed
that on to her genetically so she can
heal any kind of damage pretty quickly
that's why when she gets him at the end
of the season you kind of wonder we'll
wait a minute she just stabbed him with
her blades is he going to heal that and
come back later they're kind of
ambiguous about that but because this is
the comic book universe just don't be
surprised if Deathstroke resurfaces in a
future season they've already been
renewed for season 3 but going beyond
that will depend on a lot of things
mostly Netflix renewing their deal to
syndicate the show most of the money
from the show comes from Netflix and
from warner brothers pockets they don't
make a lot of money on it but the
Netflix deal does cover a lot of their
expenses
it'll probably wind up going to HBO max
in addition to the DC streaming service
so don't be surprised if you see show up
on that warner brothers streaming
service next year they made a couple big
changes to the Teen Titans Judas
contract
story but that was the overarching story
of season 2 Deathstroke trying to get
revenge for the death or perceived death
of one of his sons now they changed
which son it was from the comics
originally in the comics it was him
trying to get revenge for the death of
Ravager Grant Wilson Grant Wilson had
taken a contract from hive to get rid of
the Teen Titans but he died during that
attempt so Deathstroke then takes that
contract and uses Terra to get revenge
while he's also executing the contract
that's why they call it the Judas
contract because it's a contract to get
the Titans they reveal at the end of the
season though that Jericho's Spirit has
been trapped inside Deathstroke's mind
this whole time because of the way his
powers work then after she gets
Deathstroke his spirit comes in to
Ravager so it just kind of ambiguous
about what might happen with him in the
future but technically he's still alive
because of the way ravens powers work
because we know there are other planes
of existence they play it really fast
and loose with people dying which gets
to the other big moment of the episode
because there was a big death during
Teen Titans of the Judas contract which
they also changed for the TV show during
this season Cadmus labs and Mercy graves on the orders of Lex Luthor used
Superboy and Beast Boy to try and
destroy the Titans in a completely
separate plot by brainwashing them
spoiler alert one more time because
we'll be talking about who dies in the
Titans finale so here we go it winds up
being Donna Troy who's been offed a
bunch of times in the Teen Titans comics
but instead of having beast boy be the
one to do it like they were implying he
would she winds up dying because of an
accident when she was trying to save a
bunch of people from being crushed and
electrocuted I have a feeling that
people would have been way more upset if Beast Boy would have been the one to
get her while he was brainwashed and
that had to live with that guilt all
through season 3 but because Donna Troy
has come back seemingly from death many
times in the comics I wouldn't be
surprised if she somehow comes back from
death in a future season on Titans but
then you're left with the new Titans
roster heading into season 3 so
obviously Ravager is now the swap for
Donna Troy but for the most part
everybody is still there the big Batman
moment at the end of the scene too is
because they've been using the Batman
character this season in a lot of really
weird ways he's done a lot of silly
things there's been a lot of
hallucination versions of Batman inside
Nightwing's head they played really fast
and loose with what's real and what's
too
happening in people's heads so they
imply there's this big moment in an
earlier episode where they're all
brought together in a diner and Bruce
wayne/batman is wearing this white suit
talking to them about going to rescue
Nightwing you need to come back together
and go save him while they're at dinner
Starfire thanks him thank you so much
for bringing us together it really
helped us out and he says I have no idea
what you're talking about I've never
been to that diner then they reveal that
because Ravens powers are so off the
charts now that she created a mine space
Batman that's fake to bring them all
together in these scenes here so that
they could rally the team and save
Nightwing in defeat Deathstroke so for
those of you asking when was Batman real and when was he the fake hallucination
version of Batman some of the
hallucinations were clearly
hallucinations like when Nightwing was
in prison fighting Batman that was all
happening in his head the diner was fake
Batman Batman does not wear white that
should be the dead giveaway that he's
walking around in a white suit while
they're sitting at the dinner table here
he's wearing black that should be the
cue that he's real but the big season
two post-credit scene is meant to be a
teaser for the big villain of season
three and if you didn't recognize this
woman after her body change form that's
meant to be black fire star fire sister
who has just gotten rid of their parents and stolen the throne on their home world
from Starfire
Starfire also kind of lost her powers
this season and I think it's going to be
more of a mental block that you'll have
to fight through more than an actual
physical problem for those of you asking
about the Wally West version of the
flash there are rumors that he's going
to show up at some point next season
they will eventually add a speedster to
the team because the entire Justice
League exists within the Titans universe
they've already canonized all the
characters the Wonder Woman 1984 trailer
is going to be coming next week of course I'll do a video for it they'll be more
trailers for crisis and I believe
there's going to be another big trailer
for birds of prey so as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you should
see those videos when I post them but
every one click here for the brand new
crisis on Infinite Earths trailer and
click here for my brand new
Mandalorian episode 4 video thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight!